depuis que j'ai été mordu par cette araignée,
je n'ai eu qu'une semaine où ma vie m'a
semblé normale, c'est quand tu as découvert que
Peter
ce sort que tu avais bâclé a commencé à
attirer des visiteurs de tous les univers,
ce qui se passe, ils commencent à
traverser  et je ne peux pas l'empêcher de rentrer à
la maison quand tu
penses, hé, je suis sur le point de faire quelque chose
qui pourrait briser l'univers, dirige-le par
nous la prochaine fois dans les salles le 17 décembre,
c'est Peter, laisse un message ouais Peter
ça  est heureux
qui sont ces gars, hein,
si les gars ont fait de la boue, qu'est-ce qui se passe,
rappelez-moi
quand j'ai arrêté ce sort, nous avons commencé à
recevoir des visiteurs de tous les
univers, le
multivers est réel, c'est
qu'un dinosaure est
en salles le 17 décembre,
vous